whether it's the Mar-A-Lago raid or the
unselect committee hoax the perfect
Georgia phone call it was absolutely
perfect or the stormy horse face Daniels
extortion plot there it is they're all
sick
and its fake news our enemies are
desperate to stop us because they know
that we are the only ones who can stop
them and they know it very strongly and
they're looking at the polls where not
me but we are up by so much they can't
believe it is that true we'll look at
that we won twice and now we've got to
win a third time they know that we can
defeat them they know that we will
defeat them but they're not coming after
me they're coming after you right this
is a classic which is by trying to hold
me accountable for crimes for which
there is evidence
you are really being targeted it's like
no no no they're targeting you for the
things you allegedly did